halloween was once a simple holiday you
dress up you eat some candy you listen
to monster mash
very wholesome now however my producer
has informed me
that the wolksters have added halloween
to the list of cherished cultural
traditions
that they've ruined the left wingers are
apparently running
public service announcements about how
to do halloween
and i'm sorry to say my producer insists
that i
watch one so without further ado let's
roll the tape
this would be the usual one is like the
candy's poisoned so check your candy
maybe it's that it's probably that
oh it's not candy that's a pumpkin there
we go
all right first one changes an extra
piece of candy uh oh
i think i see where this is going
it's like you can't do the different
races of superheroes is that right
[Music]
you look great thank you thank you for
keeping our streets
it probably is the candy thing again
right
like the people are poisoning the candy
oh no are you freaking kidding me
they're gonna trans the kids they're
gonna make us trans the freaking kids
this is it they're actually doing it
my heroes
you see the girl is batman and the boy
is wonder woman whoever you want to be
my heroes is the government paying for
this is this like
an actual public service announcement
that
poor schmuck of a father you can see
he's got his instincts are right which
is like
maybe i shouldn't trans my kids maybe
that's like not a great thing to do for
my impressionable little kids
maybe i shouldn't dress my little boy up
like a little girl like abusive parents
have done
for all of human history but then he's
like no
my wife obviously runs the show around
here so i guess we'll do it
i'm sure my kids will love me for this
not have a lot of problems down the road
and hate me for it
they really had me there because when
when it was the kids then they go out
and they get the candy again
i thought they were going back to the
kind of traditional scaremongering of
you know someone's going to put a razor
blade and a snickers bar or something so
that that would at least have been
kind of within the the realm of normal
psa but no
no they had to had to trans the kids if
you if you have any others that you
would like
like to scar me with if you have any
others that you
want to force me to watch for some
reason uh feel free to put them in the
comments section
or send them on over to my sadistic
producer
it's so creepy i can't i don't even i
don't even i don't have no
i have no further comment this is creepy
and and
whatever that is we society should do
the opposite do the opposite of that i
don't
however if if that's
the country we made a wrong turn
somewhere
have a good halloween and uh don't trans
your kids
[Music]
you